new FPS darling the finals has released
ter reviews there's only been one issue
hackers since the betas the game has
been struggling with a pretty massive
cheating problem on certain servers and
it's gotten so bad that large swaps of
the community are calling for a specific
region to be entirely banned from
playing the
game as it turns out CS2 is hardly the
only game dealing with a fair number of
cheaters ruining the matchmaking
experience for others and after its full
release nearly 2 weeks ago the finals
became the most recent game to fall
under this Spotlight all right uh let's
see if I can get him to drill me
again there we go there it is now to be
fair the prevalence of cheaters is
usually a lot more noticeable when a
game first releases there's only so much
pen testing you can do during
development or in the betas and script
kitties are always going to find away
early on to cheat their asses off the
hope is that over time vendors get
exposed and the antiche gets stronger
unfortunately these days it's just a
wait and see type of situation unless
we're dealing with a powerful and
invasive anti-che on launch however
despite the finals being in its infancy
cheaters are apparently ruining the game
for a lot of people which has resulted
in a community backlash that I would
argue is even worse than cs2s but before
we can even get into that what the hell
is the finals well it is a team-based
FBS that's stylized like a game show it
was developed by a Stockholm Studio
composed of former dice members and
thanks in large part to its incredible
destruction it definitely has a bit of
that Battlefield feel over the past few
months it has had a couple of betas to
participate in and at the most recent
game awards it was surprise released and
in a sea of stale and unpolished
Shooters the finals has been a breath of
fresh air for a lot of people RPG
away that is is the most satisfying move
in this game by like aing mile it's so
good personally I've been playing a
little bit every day and I've been
having a great ass time with it
obviously it's going to need some
balance fixes and new content but I
think with some TLC it can have a bright
future and even blossom into a
successful esport however to a
considerable amount of the community
that will not be possible unless the
devs fix the cheating issue even since
the betas there have been countless
posts of people complaining about the
sheer amount of cheaters that are pling
the game and since launch it seems like
things have only gotten
worse but it was during those test
periods where the players who had it the
worst started calling for embark the
studio responsible to take an ironfist
approach to cheating by implementing a
region lock you see it's the belief of
many of these cheating victims that the
problem lies solely with China they feel
that all the hackers originate from
there and that the problem would be
solved if they regionlock the game some
have even pointed to the game's top
leaderboards which they allege are
exclusively comprised of Chinese players
for some they want players on China's
server to only be able to play against
each other for others they want the
entire country to be blocked from
playing the game entirely now you could
definitely make the argument that this
is collective punishment but the problem
is so bad for certain people that they
believe this is the only solution now me
personally I haven't had any issue with
cheaters in the finals yet to be honest
I haven't even noticed anything that I
would even consider to be suspicious now
this could be because I play on
different servers in a different country
but even if it did affect me and it
seemed like most of the cheaters came
from China I don't know if straight up
expelling an entire country would feel
like the right resolution listen I've
been having a ton of issues with
cheaters in CS2 but if I felt like most
of them came from New York I wouldn't
want to just ban that entire city let
alone the entire country but regardless
of how you feel about it on Sunday we
finally got a response from a community
manager on the calls for China to be
region locked and the answer was an
emphatic no in their Discord they claim
that they do not want to region lock and
that China isn't even the actual problem
alleging that many people just use
Chinese characters to avoid getting
reported the community manager also
claims that this sentiment comes from a
place of racism and xenophobia as you
can imagine members of the Discord
didn't take too kindly to these comments
but thankfully it was quickly
overshadowed the next day when a David
Embark responded to the entire situation
they claimed that there was actually a
technical issue preventing them from
Banning cheaters that they are getting
close to a fix and have already started
overhauling their anti-che they went on
to say that this is their biggest
priority and that they're in it for the
long haul this is obviously great news
they didn't say what the nature of the
technical issue was but if we take it at
face value it's a step in the right
direction now a more cynical person
might just see this as a way for the
devs to pour some cold water on the
heated lock China conversation but I'd
like to be optimistic here listen games
have tried region locks before
especially after having an overload of
alleged cheaters from from certain
regions but it never seems to actually
fix the issue that's because fixing the
actual issue requires improving anti-che
systems full stop and listen at the very
least getting some communication from
the devs on a community sentiment is
better than nothing hopefully valve is
watching this now that is where we
currently stand no region lock in sight
but a fix to the anti-che hopefully
coming soon and I'd like to hear what
you guys think about this entire
situation have you actually had an issue
with cheaters in the finals and if so do
you think a region lock is an
appropriate solution let me
know yeah play the finals if you're in
North America I guess I haven't had
problems with cheaters but it's a fun
ass game when I played the first beta or
the first Clos beta Alpha whatever it
was I was like this game kind of stinks
the time to kill was bad the respawn
time just felt really awkward but now
they seem to fix it the balance is still
messed up but it's a lot of fun it's a
lot of fun